billion people across the globe are
expected to watch Tomorrow's World Cup
final between Argentina and France 32
national teams are taking part in the
competition which is the Pinnacle of
soccer achievement the symbol of that
success is winning the World Cup itself
an 18-carat gold trophy created and
cared for by a small Italian firm
outside Milan Chris livesay has the
story
Jubilation and pandemonium that can only
be inspired by one object
World Cup trophy as France paraded it
through Paris after its victory in 2018.
the Holy Grail of soccer was born here
in this Italian Workshop outside Milan
in 1971 unlike its predecessor it was
designed by Silvio gatsuniga to be
filmed and photographed from all
directions as Overjoyed players would
hoist it into the air over the decades
West Germany was the first country to
win the honor in 1974. since then it's
been through a lot
after the winning team has savored
Victory it gets to keep a replica while
the original is sent back to the factory
in Italy for touch-ups says the CEO and
granddaughter of the man who hired the
artist it's not true and it's loved so
it comes to be here to be like uh in a
beauty Farm we God played it again and
we fix like the small scratches on the
malachite we engraved the base with the
winning team but yes it's a loved Trophy
and the love sign are well shown
love signs reflected in 18 karat gold
measuring 15 inches and weighing 13
pounds depicting she says the world held
Aloft by two angels of victory
it's a double-edged sword for these
Craftsmen proud Italians forced to
swallow defeat after their country
failed to qualify for this year's
tournament
sing our cup raised into the air is very
emotional says Marco costanzo I'm
trembling with anticipation I'm so proud
to work here
with their handiwork on the podium no
matter who wins they can all feel like
champions for CBS Saturday morning Chris
livesay Rome
Nice Shot I love how she said it's not
ruined it's loved yeah I like everything
that happens to it as the team has it I
got to hold the World Cup trophy once
that's cool they had the replicas which
is the exact same as the real one I
guess that you were on Boston after
Italy one in 2006. I wanted that picture
Jeff I'll find it I'll find